today i'm here to talk to you about
health canada's authorization of the
first bivalent covid19 vaccine in canada
health canada has authorized an updated
version of the modernist spike max kobit
19 vaccine for adults 18 years of age
and older and this vaccine is known as a
bivalent vaccine because it targets two
coronavirus strains the original sars
cov2 virus from 2019 and the omicron ba1
variant
after completing a thorough and
independent scientific review of the
evidence health canada has determined
that this bivalent modernist bike backs
booster has met the requirements for the
safety and the effectiveness
from the regulations
this marks a milestone in canada's
response to this pandemic
up to now all authorized coping 19
vaccines in canada have targeted one
strain of the virus the original stars
cov2virus from 2019. these vaccines have
served us well over time and continue to
be very effective at preventing what
matters most severe illness
hospitalization and death
with billions of vaccine administered
around the world we now have more
knowledge about how vaccines respond to
new variants and with the omicron
variant now circulating we know that the
existing vaccines can be less effective
or weighing over time
one of the advantages of the mrna
vaccines is that they can be adapted
relatively quickly to new variants and
scientists and vaccine manufacturers are
updating covid19 vaccines by adding
other ingredients which specifically
target the circulating virus strains
for example each dose of the new
bivalent modernist bike fax vaccine
contains 50 micrograms of mrna with 25
micrograms targeting the original stars
cov2 virus strain and 25 micrograms
specifically targeting the omicron ba1
subvariant it's essentially two vaccines
in one
health canada's decision to authorize
this new bivalent vaccine was based on
data from a clinical trial that showed
that a booster dose of the bivalent
moderna vaccine triggers a strong immune
response against both the omicron ba1
and the original sars kobe 2 virus
strains
while the vaccine was designed to more
specifically target the omicron ba1
subvariant we know that this vaccine
also generates a good immune response
against the omicron subvariants ba4 and
ba5 that have more recently emerged
health canada is currently reviewing a
submission from pfizer buying tech for a
bivalent vaccine that also targets the
original stars kovi ii strain as well as
the omicron ba1 subvariant
to ensure we have as many options as
possible for dealing with current and
future variants we have reached out to
both visor biotech and moderna to
request that they file submissions for
vaccines specifically targeting the ba-4
and ba-5 subveriance we are awaiting
confirmation on their plans including
submission timelines the national
advisory committee on immunization or
nasty provided recommendations for
booster doses in preparation for the
fall to better protect against an
anticipated increase of covenanting
activity during these months today nasa
has updated this guidance to reflect the
authorization of bivalent vaccines
for adults 18 years of age and older
nasty recommends that a bivalent covet
19 booster vaccine should be offered as
a booster if the bivalent booster is not
readily available an original mrna covet
19 vaccine should be offered to ensure
timely protection it is important to be
aware that both the original and by
valid covet 19 vaccines are effective as
a booster for adolescents 12 to 17 years
of age with moderately or severe
immunocompromising conditions and or who
have biological or social risk factors
that place them at high risk of severe
outcomes from covert 19 based on expert
opinion and the data in adults nasty
also recommends that the bivalent
vaccine may be offered to this
population
individuals who are eligible for
boosters this fall especially those at
increased risk for severe illness from
cova 19 should not delay their planned
vaccination in anticipation of a
bivalent vaccine
anyone choosing to delay a booster dose
in anticipation of a new vaccine should
carefully consider their individual risk
based on provincial and territorial
projections there will be enough supply
of the modernist spike facts bivalent
covet 19 vaccine in canada for everyone
18 years of age and older this fall and
winter
canada is well positioned to offer a
robust bivalent booster campaign and
shipments will begin arriving over the
coming days and months
you know what we see is that over time
you know depending on sort of how you
know variants evolve and so on uh we we
can certainly see that
down the road it might be a case that on
a whatever regular basis or so uh we we
might be uh changing quote that the
formulation of the the types of uh
strains in the covet 19 vaccines based
on
what's happening both here in canada and
around the world so this is i think a
major step in in acknowledging that uh
the kova 19 you know uh let's say the
stars cov2 virus continues to evolve and
certainly because of the omicron variant
being sort of the big sort of a change
that has uh
had an impact in terms of vaccine
effectiveness uh because of its immune
escape properties uh that's why we're
offering uh or that's why the companies
have developed the bivalent vaccine once
you start getting to a sort of the
sub-variant so ba1 four or five uh
certainly i would say that at the heart
of it they're re sort of the original
sort of the ba1 uh uh you know uh
variant uh uh uh sort of uh indicative
of omni omicron is different enough from
the original strain that as you know
we've seen from the evidence to date it
offers good cross protection across the
range of of the other uh
sub-variants for omicron lab for example
ba45 and i think we need to be careful
it can't just be a matter of sort trying
to catch up with what might be the
latest circulating virus you need to
look at the the whole of what's
happening here in canada uh around the
world uh looking very uh i i would say
in depth at sort of the the changes in
the in the the in the virus not just
quote an individual sub-variant but
maybe you know what might be a major
change or be in the spike protein or you
know other uh
other factors that might uh you know uh
lead towards uh having a let's say
another sort of uh you know formulation
of the vaccine so that's what i would
say is sort of the big picture moving
forward
recognizing that the virus will continue
to evolve and
as
as such the vaccines will also continue
to evolve to keep up in offering
canadians and others around the world
the best possible protection